Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Hello, welcome to The Rest is History. I've never been a massive connoisseur of Senegalese history. In fact, the first time that Senegal really impinged on my consciousness was when Senegal beat France in the opening match of the 2002 World Cup in Japan and South Korea. The former colonial power, Dominic. It's former colonial power, Dominic. It's former colonial power.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要获取每周的独家加更节目、无广告收听、剧集的抢先体验，以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。大家好，欢迎收听《历史的余烬》。我从来都不是塞内加尔历史的超级鉴赏家。事实上，塞内加尔真正进入我的意识，是在 2002 年日本和韩国世界杯的揭幕战中，塞内加尔击败了法国队。前殖民宗主国，多米尼克。是前殖民宗主国，多米尼克。是前殖民宗主国。
Exactly. So it was a sort of moment charged with historic significance and not purely sporting history. And Tom, you volunteered to dip your toes into Senegalese history for this episode in our World Cup marathon. And what have you come up with? Well, so I vaguely knew about Senegal's prowess on the football field, both because of the victory over France that you mentioned.
没错。所以这是一个充满历史意义的时刻，而不仅仅纯粹是体育史。汤姆，你主动提出在我们这次世界杯马拉松系列节目中，涉足塞内加尔历史。你都了解到了什么？嗯，所以我隐约知道塞内加尔在足球领域的实力，一方面是因为你刚才提到的战胜法国队的胜利。
Also, I think they won the African Cup of Nations. They did indeed, yes. So they're obviously very, very good at football. There's one other thing that I know about Senegal, which is its most famous tourist attraction, and which featured on, is one of the 12 original World Heritage Sites that were chosen by UNESCO in 1978. And now there are lots and lots and lots of them. So Stonehenge Landscape, for instance, is a UNESCO World Heritage Site for now.
还有，我想他们还赢得过非洲国家杯。确实如此，是的。所以他们显然非常非常擅长足球。关于塞内加尔，我还有一件事知道，那就是它最著名的旅游景点，这也是 1978 年被联合国教科文组织选为最初 12 个世界遗产之一的地方。现在这类遗产已经有很多很多很多了。比如，巨石阵景观目前就是联合国教科文组织世界遗产。
Maybe removed if they go ahead with their tunnel who knows um and actually four of those um 12 original world heritage sites dominic uh feature in our series so the galapagos islands for ecuador we yes will feature in our episode on on uh on ecuador um two uh in our polish episodes of the massive salt mine that goes for hundreds of miles uh central crrakow, and Senegal's most visited tourist attraction, which is on the Isle of Gore. And you may be wondering, well, have you heard of Gore? I haven't, Tom. I'm looking forward to you educating me about it. Well, I won't educate you. I will let the UNESCO website educate you. So this is how they describe Gore. The island of Gore lies off the coast of Senegal,
如果他们继续修建隧道，以后可能会被除名，谁知道呢。实际上，多米尼克，那 12 个最初的世界遗产中有四个都在我们的系列节目中出现过。厄瓜多尔的加拉帕戈斯群岛，我们是的，将会在我们关于厄瓜多尔的单期节目中出现；还有两个在我们关于波兰的节目中，一个是延伸数百英里的宏大盐矿，另一个是克拉科夫市中心；以及塞内加尔访问量最大的旅游景点——戈雷岛。你可能在想，好吧，你听说过戈雷吗？我没听说过，汤姆。我很期待你为我科普一下。嗯，我不会科普。我会让联合国教科文组织网站来为你科普。他们是这样描述戈雷岛的：戈雷岛位于塞内加尔海岸外，
opposite Dakar. From the 15th to the 19th century, it was the largest slave trading center on the African coast, ruled in succession by the Portuguese, Dutch, English, and French. Its architecture is characterized by the contrast between the grim slave quarters and the elegant houses of the slave traders. Today, it continues to serve as a reminder of human exploitation and as a sanctuary for reconciliation. And the most famous building on Gorée is La Maison des Esclaves, so the House of Slaves, which was built in 1776. It is notorious as a holding center for enslaved Africans. It's kind of redwashed. It's got cellars with kind of iron bars in it. And it has a doorway that looks out onto the Atlantic Ocean. And this is celebrated as the door of no return. And there are famous photographs of it. There's a picture of a silhouetted woman standing in this doorway, kind of leaning against it. And this is the door out of which, as the Gorée tourist board puts it, millions of African slaves took the final step from their home continent and onto the slave ships that would transport them if they survived the journey to the new world.
与达喀尔隔海相望。从 15 世纪到 19 世纪，它是非洲海岸最大的奴隶贸易中心，先后被葡萄牙人、荷兰人、英国人和法国人统治。其建筑的特点是阴森的奴隶囚室与奴隶贩子优雅的住宅之间形成鲜明对比。今天，它继续作为人类剥削的警示以及实现和解的圣地。戈雷岛上最著名的建筑是奴隶堡（La Maison des Esclaves），即奴隶之家，建于 1776 年。它作为关押非洲奴隶的中转站而臭名昭著。它被粉刷成了一种红褐色。里面有装着铁条的地窖。它有一扇面向大西洋的门。这里被誉为“不归门”。有许多关于它的著名照片。有一张照片是一个女性剪影站在这个门里，斜倚着它。这就是戈雷岛旅游局所说的那扇门，数百万非洲奴隶从这里迈出了离开祖国大陆的最后一步，踏上了奴隶船；如果他们能在通往新世界的航程中幸存下来，这些船就会将他们运走。
Gosh, so it's a very sort of baleful place, basically. So basically, I'm putting my hands up, this is pretty much the only image of Senegal that came into my mind when we were divvying up all the various countries. And I thought it would be interesting to put some history to this image that was kind of so vivid in my mind. I mean, it's kind of emblematic of the slave trade, this idea of going through a door forever, the door of no return. Terrifying, terrifying thought.
天哪，所以这基本上是一个非常不祥的地方。所以基本上，我得承认，当我们瓜分各个国家时，这就是我脑海中浮现的关于塞内加尔的唯一影像。我觉得把历史赋予这个在我脑海中如此生动的影像会很有趣。我的意思是，奴隶贸易的这种概念——永远地穿过一扇门，即“不归门”——可以说是奴隶贸易的象征。这是一种令人毛骨悚然、极其可怕的想法。
And the House of Slaves, it's been a museum for many, many decades. So I think Senegal became independent from France in 1960, something like that. Right. And this opened as a museum very shortly afterwards, so 1962. It's been visited by the Pope, by John Paul II, by Nelson Mandela, by a range of American presidents, so Bill Clinton, George W. Bush, Barack Obama. But above all, it's a place of pilgrimage for African-Americans. And basically, I mean, it is, I would guess, the single most
奴隶之家作为一个博物馆已经有很多很多年了。所以我想塞内加尔在 1960 年左右从法国独立出来，差不多是这样。没错。而这里在不久之后就作为博物馆开放了，即 1962 年。教宗若望·保禄二世、纳尔逊·曼德拉以及一系列美国总统，如比尔·克林顿、乔治·W·布什、巴拉克·奥巴马，都曾参观过这里。但最重要的是，它是非裔美国人的朝圣地。基本上，我的意思是，我想它是……
celebrated emblem of the Atlantic slave trade. And when you say celebrated, you don't mean people are letting off fireworks and jumping around in delight. You mean, you know, it's the most well-known because of its… It's a place of pilgrimage. It's a place of pilgrimage. Yeah. But it was a place of horror, I suppose. It serves as a brilliant visual image of the horror.
大西洋奴隶贸易最著名的象征。当你用“著名”这个词时，你并不是指人们在燃放烟花、兴奋地跳跃。你是说，你知道的，它是最广为人知的，因为它的……这是一个朝圣地。这是一个朝圣地。是的。但我想那曾是一个充满恐怖的地方。它展现了恐怖的绝佳视觉影像。
The sense of a permanent departure. And so that's why coming back to it, I guess, that's the resonance and the power of it. That expression, the door of no return, I mean. Very chilling. Very potent, yeah. So the history of this is that basically there doesn't seem to have been anything much on Gore before the Portuguese arrived because there's not very much water
一种永久离别的感觉。我想这就是为什么回过头来看，这正是它的共鸣和力量所在。“不归门”这个词，我的意思是。非常令人不寒而栗。非常有感染力，是的。所以这段历史的背景是，在葡萄牙人到来之前，戈雷岛上似乎并没有什么东西，因为那里没有太多水。
there and it seems to have been completely infested by termites. And prepossessing. Not really kind of ideal real estate. Yes. So the Portuguese obviously love that kind of place. We did our episodes on the Portuguese voyages of discovery. It becomes a trading post for them. And basically over the next 100 200 300 years it's just endlessly swapping hands so the the dutch take control of it the english take control of it the french take control of it and by the 18th century the french are the kind of you know basically the french putting down roots they're periodically obedient to the rhythms of france's
而且似乎完全饱受白蚁侵害。并不怎么吸引人。并不是那种理想的房地产。是的。所以葡萄牙人显然很喜欢那种地方。我们做过关于葡萄牙远航发现的节目，它成了他们的贸易站。基本上，在接下来的 100 年、200 年、300 年里，它不断易手。荷兰人控制它，英国人控制它，法国人控制它。到了 18 世纪，法国人成为了那种……你知道的，基本上法国人开始扎根。他们定期顺应法国与英国战争的节奏，
wars with britain the the british might come in take over, but only for kind of a few years at a time. It's basically become French. And 1783, the French established their rule there for good. And, you know, in various forms, they will rule over Gorée and the hinterland of Senegal until 1960 and independence. So why Gorée and not say further inland and the most obvious answer for that is that the um the inland is incredibly incredibly dangerous it is very very very dangerous to people's health so muslim writers, Muslim geographers, they say of this stretch of the
英国人可能会来接管，但也只是持续几年时间。它基本上变成了法国的领土。1783 年，法国人在那里确立了永久统治。而且，你知道的，以各种形式，他们将统治戈雷和塞内加尔腹地，直到 1960 年独立。那么，为什么是戈雷，而不是更深入内陆的地方呢？最显而易见的答案是，内陆地区简直太危险了。对人们的健康而言非常非常危险。所以穆斯林作家、穆斯林地理学家在谈到这段海岸线时说，
coastline, if you go there, you will almost certainly die. So there's a geographer in the 11th century called Al-Bakri, who says it's almost impossible to go there and not fall ill. And I'm sure you remember, we talked about this with Karl Harper. And we talked about just how ravaged by disease it is. So I've just got his book here um the the crude death rate in the 18th century was 270 people per 1000 so um yeah so one in four an ordinary pre-modern society says might have a crude death rate of 30 per 1000 yeah and every year along the stretch of the coast more than a quarter of the europeans resident there perished so essentially you want to keep you know as many breezes and as many
如果你去那里，你几乎必死无疑。因此，11 世纪有一位名叫阿尔-巴克里的地理学家说，去那里而不生病几乎是不可能的。我确信你还记得，我们和卡尔·哈珀谈过这个。我们谈到了那里遭受疾病肆虐的程度。我刚好有他的书在这里，18 世纪的粗死亡率是每千人 270 人。所以，是的，四分之一。一个普通的古代社会，每千人的粗死亡率可能是 30 人左右。是的，每年沿着这段海岸线，居住在那里的欧洲人有四分之一以上丧生。所以基本上，你希望在自己与大陆上的微生物和病原体之间，尽可能保持最多的微风和海流。
currents between you and the microbes and the pathogens that lie on the mainland as possible and just to give people a sense if they're not familiar with it so we're on the coast of west africa um below it's part of dakar now it's it's it's part of the the vast kind of sprawl of dakar but back then it wasn't it was a kind of distinct entity yeah dare i use the word liminal um so it's on the it's on the border zone it's a place that is neither one thing nor the other so it's not an academic podcast no it's so it's it's african but it's not continental. I mean, I think that's the kind of key thing. Yeah.
为了让大家对地理位置有个概念（如果他们不熟悉的话），我们在西非海岸，它属于达喀尔的一部分，现在它是达喀尔广阔城市蔓延的一部分，但在当时并非如此，它是一个独特的实体。我敢用“边缘”这个词吗？所以它处于边界地带，是一个介于两者之间、非此非彼的地方。这不是一门学术播客。不，它是非洲的，但又不是大陆的。我的意思是，我认为这是关键所在。是的。
You look one way, you have Africa. You look the other way, you have the Atlantic. And obviously, if you're traders coming from the Atlantic, looking to pick up trade from Africa, which of course would include slaves, and then take it across the sea, you know, very, very well positioned. It's still dangerous, though. I mean, even on Gore well positioned it's still dangerous though i mean even on gore it's dangerous and so um basically europeans are very very reluctant to stay there any length of time
你看向一个方向，是广袤的非洲。看向另一个方向，是大西洋。显然，如果你是从大西洋来的商人，想要从非洲收购商品（当然包括奴隶），然后把它们运过大海，你知道的，这里的地理位置非常非常优越。不过，它仍然很危险。我的意思是，即使在戈雷，地理位置优越，但它依然很危险。所以，基本上欧洲人在那里停留很长时间的意愿非常非常低。
yeah um and so what they do is that they will marry local women uh and this is a practice that goes right the way back to the portuguese time so these these these women who are um uh local they come to be called senores right is that how you pronounce it, Dominic? Seigniores, I guess. So the European traders will almost invariably leave and their wives, and I use wives slightly in inverted commas, they come to serve as the agents of their absent husbands and increasingly as traders in their own right.
是的，所以他们会娶当地女性为妻。这种做法可以一直追溯到葡萄牙人统治时期。这些当地女性被称为西涅尔（Signares），对吧？多米尼克，这是怎么发音的？大概是 Signiores 吧。所以欧洲商人几乎总是会离开，而他们的妻子（我给“妻子”加上一点引号）则充当他们不在身边的丈夫的代理人，并逐渐成为独立的商人。
And they will then bring their children up as their own, and they will then raise their sons as heirs, as people who will inherit these kind of trading business. And so you get these very, very wealthy Franco-African trading dynasties. And these are the people who are building uh the houses um on gore at the end of the 18th century so for instance the the man who builds the house of slaves with the door of no return yeah he's the son of a signora and a french surgeon and his sister um who also marries a frenchman who um runs away because there's a yellow fever outbreak, she is also a player in the slave trade. And that's late 18th century. That's late 18th century. So essentially, the slaving that
然后她们会把自己的孩子当成自己的孩子抚养成人，把儿子培养成继承人，继承这些贸易生意。于是你便拥有了这些非常非常富裕的法非（Franco-African）贸易世家。正是这些人在 18 世纪末在戈雷岛上建造了房屋。例如，建造带有“不归门”的奴隶之家的那个人，就是一位西涅尔女性与一名法国外科医生的儿子。他的姐姐（或者妹妹）也嫁给了一个法国人——由于爆发黄热病而逃跑了，她也是奴隶贸易中的一个重要人物。那是 18 世纪末。那是 18 世纪末。所以本质上，发生在戈雷岛上的奴隶贸易，
is happening on Gorée, it's not just French, it's not just African, it's the meeting point between them. And this is expressed through these kind of Creole dynasties that emerged there. 1794, the French Republic bans the slave trade. Napoleon in due course will re-legitimize it, but it does not resume from Gorée. So 1794 is the terminus for the slave trade. And so the Franco-African trading dynasties move into the peanut trade, Dominic. Peanut trade, like Jimmy Carter. Like Jimmy Carter, yes. Very like Jimmy Carter. And with the kind of growing industrialization, growing size of ships, the harbor facilities on Gorée are inadequate. And so they move to the mainland. And the result of that is that the
不仅仅是法国的，也不仅仅是非洲的，而是两者交汇的起点。这通过在那里兴起的克里奥尔（Creole）王朝表现出来。1794 年，法兰西共和国废除了奴隶贸易。拿破仑日后会将其重新合法化，但它并没有在戈雷岛恢复。因此，1794 年是奴隶贸易的终点。此后，法非贸易世家转向了花生贸易，多米尼克。花生贸易，就像吉米·卡特那样。就像吉米·卡特，是的。非常像吉米·卡特。随着工业化的发展和船只体量的增大，戈雷岛上的港口设施已经不够用了。因此，他们搬到了大陆。其结果就是，
architecture of 18th century Gorée survives. So we always see this. It's trading cities that get left behind that kind of have the historic architecture, because if they don't, they get demolished and replaced and so on. And so it serves as a kind of very atmospheric reminder of the world of the slave trade just before its abolition. Which means that in 1960, when Senegal becomes independent, Gorée is there as an emblem of the slave trade, but a very picturesque emblem of the slave trade with beautiful kind of buildings, narrow winding roads, no real development. And so it has historical interest and it is picturesque. So it's a sort of a far more horrific equivalent of formerly industrial kind of villages in Britain,
18 世纪戈雷岛的建筑风格得以保存下来。我们经常看到这种情况：只有那些被遗弃的贸易城市才保留了历史建筑，因为如果不被遗弃，它们就会被拆除、取代等等。因此，它就像是对废除奴隶贸易前夕奴隶贸易世界的一个充满氛围感的提醒。这意味着在 1960 年塞内加尔独立时，戈雷岛作为奴隶贸易的象征而存在，但这是一个非常如画的奴隶贸易象征，拥有美丽的建筑、狭窄蜿蜒的道路，没有真正的开发。因此，它既具有历史价值又风景如画。所以它有点像英国那些曾经的工业村庄的更加恐怖的版本，
let's say, which were left behind by economic change and then preserved and untouched. Well, like Venice, say. Right. Yes. So Venice is a great trading city, but its decline begins in the 18th century so that when it loses its independence at the end of the 18th century, it's preserved. Yeah. So I think this is kind of rather similar. Although this is charged, this has a kind of moral charge, right? Because of the trade. It is. And it comes to possess this particular charge because of the guy who becomes the curator of the House of Slaves, a man called Boubacar Joseph Ndia.
比方说，它们被经济变革抛在脑后，然后被原封不动地保存了下来。嗯，就像威尼斯一样。没错。是的。威尼斯是一个伟大的贸易城市，但它的衰落始于 18 世纪，因此当它在 18 世纪末失去独立时，它被完整地保存了下来。是的。所以我觉得这有点类似。尽管这里带有某种情感色彩，对吧？因为奴隶贸易。确实如此。而且它之所以具有这种特殊的色彩，是因为后来成为奴隶之家馆长的那个人，一个名叫布巴卡尔·约瑟夫·恩迪亚耶（Boubacar Joseph Ndiaye）的人。
And I hope I pronounced that right. I may not have done. It's N-D-A-I-A-Y-E. And he is a genius at promoting it and he is the guy who who pushes the idea that um a million slaves have left through the door of no return that 20 million have been exported from gore over the 400 year period of the slave trade from there 20 million from gore alone That's very much what this museum is saying. Yeah. So it's up there on the billboards.
希望我发音准确。也许没有。拼写是 N-D-I-A-Y-E。他是宣传这方面的天才，正是他极力推崇这样一种观点：有数百万奴隶通过不归门离开，在长达 400 年的奴隶贸易期间，有 2000 万奴隶从戈雷岛出口，仅从戈雷岛就出口了 2000 万。这正是这个博物馆所传达的信息。是的。所以它被写在了广告牌上。
And so from the 70s onwards, so it's there in the 60s, but it's in the 70s that it really takes off as a kind of major tourist attraction. So this is when it gets put on the register of UNESCO World Heritage Sites, one of the first 12 sites anywhere class who want to commemorate how it was that they came to America. And there are no real memorials to the slave trade in the United States itself. So there are memorials to slavery, but not to the trade, I suppose. So the plantations, but you wouldn't go to a plantation, would you?
所以从 70 年代开始（虽然 60 年代它就存在了），它在 70 年代真正作为主要的旅游景点起飞了。正是在这个时候，它被列入联合国教科文组织世界遗产名录，成为全球最初的 12 个遗产地之一。那些想要缅怀祖先如何来到美洲的人们来到这里。而美国本土其实并没有真正的奴隶贸易纪念碑。所以有关于奴隶制的纪念碑，但我想没有关于贸易的。比如种植园，但你总不会去参观种植园吧？
I mean, it would be no no there's there's no there's no kind of emotional focus for the sense of of grief and pain and suffering and so this you know this door the door of no return the house of slaves on this kind of exquisitely beautiful but menacing island is is kind of perfect um you know there are other sites as well but they tend to be in places that are either very um politically unstable at the time like ghana yeah so in the 60s there's you know it's it's unstable or economically unstable so like tanzania or guinea um so senegal is relatively stable relatively prosperous. And also the 1970s is when you have Alex Helly's book, Roots, which is made into a television film, which again kind of dramatizes in a brilliant way
我的意思是，那不会……没有，那里没有一种情感焦点来承载悲伤、痛苦和苦难的情感。所以，这扇门，“不归门”，这座精致美丽却又带有一丝威胁感的岛上的奴隶之家，可以说是完美的。你知道，还有其他遗址，但它们往往位于当时政治非常动荡的地方，比如加纳。所以在 60 年代，那里是不稳定的；或者是经济不稳定，比如坦桑尼亚或几内亚。所以塞内加尔相对稳定、相对繁荣。此外，在 20 世纪 70 年代，亚历克斯·哈利的小说《根》（Roots）问世，并被改编成电视电影，这再次以一种极其精彩的方式将大西洋奴隶贸易的全部恐怖戏剧化地表现出来。
the whole horror of the Atlantic slave trade. Right. I mean, Roots is 19, the novel is 1976, the TV series is 1977. And as you you say it's impossible to overestimate the effect that had on african americans um and their sort of their desire to find out about their own history and and this sort of idea of a pilgrimage back to find your roots and whatnot and as i say the that idea of a door of no return is so haunting that that is the image that i had in my mind when i said that i would i would do senegal because i yeah you know i i had that image um and so i've i've now given you the backstory of how it is that um it came to be the icon of uh senegalese
对。我的意思是，《根》的小说是 1976 年出版的，电视剧是 1977 年播出的。正如你所说，它对非裔美国人产生的影响是无法高估的，以及他们寻找自己历史的渴望，这种重返根源朝圣的想法等等。正如我所说，“不归门”的概念是如此令人挥之不去，以至于当我答应做塞内加尔这一期时，我脑子里浮现的就是这个画面，因为我，你知道的，我脑子里有这个画面。所以我现在已经向你们介绍了它是如何成为塞内加尔历史乃至非裔美国人历史的标志的背景故事。但是，在这之上悬着一个问题，这与我在开始研究伊斯兰教起源时提出的问题相当相似：这实际上是真的吗？这背后的信源是什么？
history that it is and indeed of african-american history um but there is hanging over hanging over it a question that um is rather similar to the question that i came to ask when i started to work on uh the origins of islam which is is it actually true what are the sources for this okay and so um i think this might be a diplomatic moment to take a break. And when we come back, we'll look and see to what extent was the door of no return actually what the tourist industry says it was. Brilliant. OK, see you after the break. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip.
好吧，所以我想现在是一个外交式的休息好时机。当我们回来时，我们将看看“不归门”在多大程度上真的如旅游业所说的那样。太棒了。好的，休息后见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《娱乐的余烬》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、一丝不苟的秀场八卦。
And on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The rest is history we're talking about the house of slaves on the island of gore in senegal um and tom in the first half you painted this very evocative picture of the island of the house of slaves and the sort of the lanes and streets around it and of this particular place this incredibly haunting place,
在我们的问答环节中，我们将拉开娱乐业的帷幕，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、加更节目以及现场门票的抢先购买权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史的余烬》，我们正在讨论塞内加尔戈雷岛上的奴隶之家。汤姆，在上半场，你为我们描绘了一幅非常生动的画面，关于这个岛屿、奴隶之家以及它周围的小巷和街道，还有这个特殊的地方，这个令人难以忘怀的地方——
the door of no return, through which, how many people was it again? A million. A million people. A million slaves passed, never to return, on their journey to the new world. The problem is that there is no documentary evidence for this claim at all. Right, okay. And there's also no documentary evidence for the claim that 20 million slaves were exported from Gorée itself.
“不归门”。有多少人通过这扇门？一百万。一百万。一百万奴隶从这里经过，踏上了通往新世界的旅程，再也没有回来。问题是，根本没有任何文献证据支持这种说法。好吧，明白了。而且也没有任何文献证据支持从戈雷岛本身出口了 2000 万奴隶的说法。
Because that's a colossal, I mean, that was an eye-watering claim. So one of the things that is happening in the study of the Atlantic slave trade is that over the course of the 60s and 70s, at exactly the same time as Gorée is being kind of hyped up, you get scholars in US history departments who are
因为这是一个极其庞大的数字，我的意思是，这是一个让人咋舌的说法。在大西洋奴隶贸易的研究中，有一件事正在发生：在 60 年代和 70 年代期间，就在戈雷岛被大肆炒作的同时，美国历史系的学者们正在
conducting systematic research into the Atlantic slave trade. And what this research indicates is that most of the slaves who are being taken from Senegal are departing from depots at the mouths of the Senegal and Gamba rivers, which lie north and south of Gorée. So not from the House of Slaves at all? No. And the House of Slaves itself, it seems, was never used as a warehouse for slaves. So the cellars in the basement, where you go down there and the guides will say, this
对大西洋奴隶贸易进行系统的研究。这项研究表明，从塞内加尔被运走的绝大多数奴隶，都是从位于戈雷岛南北两侧的塞内加尔河口和冈比亚河口的仓库出发的。所以根本不是从奴隶之家出发的？是的。而且奴隶之家本身，似乎也从未被用作奴隶仓库。所以当你走到地下室时，导游会说，
is where slaves were kept before they were transported. They may have been used to house slaves, but if so, they were domestic slaves. They were slaves that were owned by the merchants who owned the house. So they were slaves who weren't going anywhere. They were working for the... Yeah, they're not going to... Yeah, exactly. And the door of no return was absolutely not an exit point
这里就是奴隶被运送前关押的地方。这里或许曾被用来关押奴隶，但即便如此，它们也是家奴。它们是拥有这栋房子的商人们所拥有的奴隶。所以这些奴隶哪儿也不去。他们是在为……是的，他们不会……是的，完全如此。而且“不归门”绝对不是一个出口，
because apparently below it there are rocks. And so it would be dangerous for boats to dock there. So were slaves being transported from the island of Gorée at all? Yeah, the estimate is it's about 500 per annum. Okay. So, I mean, a number, but nowhere near the number that would justify 20 million or whatever. Exactly so. Now, the guy who comes particularly associated with this research is probably the most eminent historian of the
因为显然它下方就是岩石。因此，船只靠岸会非常危险。那么，奴隶究竟有没有从戈雷岛运输出去过呢？是的，估计每年大约有 500 人。好吧。所以，这是一个数字，但远远达不到可以证明 2000 万或其他数字的规模。完全如此。与这项研究联系最紧密的学者，可能是他那一代人中最杰出的大西洋奴隶贸易历史学家，一位名叫菲利普·D·柯丁（Philip D. Curtin）的人，他是约翰斯·霍普金斯大学的历史学教授。他的书《大西洋奴隶贸易：一个普查》（The Atlantic Slave Trade: A Census）于 1969 年出版，可以说是具有绝对开创性意义的。他对强加给戈雷岛的种种说法进行了非常非常坦率的谴责。他说整个故事都是假的。他称奴隶之家是一场骗局。他称这是一场诈骗。显然，这让塞内加尔旅游局感到很不高兴。是的。而且这让人不高兴，首先是因为，你知道的，没人愿意听到自己的主要旅游景点被斥为骗局。但也是因为菲利普·柯丁是个白人美国人。
Atlantic slave trade of his generation, a man called Philip D. Curtin, who is the professor of history at John Hopkins. His book, The Atlantic Slave Trader Census came out in 1969, and it was kind of absolutely groundbreaking. And he's very, very upfront in condemning the claims to be made for Gorée. He says the whole story is phony. He calls the House of Slaves a hoax. He calls it a scam. And obviously, this does not go down well with the Senegalese tourist authority. No. And it doesn't go down well, firstly, because, you know, it's not what you want to hear, have your, you know, your prime tourist attraction condemned as a hoax. But it's also because Philip Curtin is white and American.
因此有一种强烈的看法：白人美国人来破坏、指手画脚，并且基本上说这些研究粗制滥造，这完全符合外交礼仪吗？因此，在 90 年代爆发了巨大的争议，这些争议实际上往往是通过法国的《世界报》（Le Monde）而不是在美国的报纸上进行的。但基本上我要说的是，现在柯丁的观点似乎已经被普遍接受了。正如我所说，除了“不归门”的形象外，我对这一切一无所知。只是在过去的一周左右时间里泛读了一下相关资料。这基本上是西方学者中的共识。芝加哥大学有一位名叫拉ルフ·奥斯汀（Ralph Austin）的教授，他说，真的没有历史学家相信奴隶之家是他们所宣称的那样，也没有人相信戈雷岛在奴隶贸易中具有统计学上的重要性。在塞内加尔，有一位非常杰出的历史学家阿杜利·卡马拉（Abdoulier Kamara），同样，希望我发音准确。他说他是一位历史学家，他不被允许带有感伤情绪。所以，是的，他说奴隶之家提供了一种强烈而强大的感伤历史，但我是一名历史学家，我不允许带有感伤情绪。这也在旅游指南中渗透下去了。比如《孤独星球》西非指南中写道：戈雷虚构的历史，归根结底不过是政府官员和旅游公司对那些满怀寻找文化之根的真诚愿望来到这里的人们进行的一种情感操纵。天哪，这评价相当严厉。
And so there's very much a feeling that, is it entirely diplomatic for white Americans to undermine, to be lecturing and to kind of be basically saying that the research is shoddy. And so there is a huge controversy that rages through the nineties, actually often conducted in the pages of Le Monde in France rather than in America. But basically I would say now that Curtin's case seems to be pretty generally accepted. As I say, I knew nothing about this apart from the image of the door of no return. Just kind of reading around, so I've been reading around it past week or so. It's pretty much the consensus among Western scholars. So there's a professor at Chicago called Ralph Austin, and he says there are literally no historians who believe the slave house is what they're claiming it to be, or that believes Goree was statistically significant in terms of the slave
是的，确实很严厉。确实很严厉。所以，我的意思是，我认为这引发了各种有趣且敏感的问题。显而易见第一个问题是（由于我不是非裔美国人，所以我没有资格回答）：历史被夸大了，这重要吗？我找到了许多非裔美国人的引言，他们基本上说，例如，2004 年的《时代》周刊就这个事情做过一篇报道。
trade. In Senegal, there's a very distinguished historian, Abdoulier Kamara, again, I hope I've pronounced that right, who says that he is a historian, I'm not allowed to be sentimental. So yeah, he says says the house of slaves offers a strong powerful sentimental history but i'm a historian i'm not allowed to be sentimental and it's also percolated down to the tourist guide so the lonely planet guide to west africa gore's fabricated history boils down to an emotional manipulation by government officials and tour companies of people who come here as part of a genuine search for cultural roots. Crack it, that's pretty strong.
其中引用了一位来自华盛顿特区的中学教师的话，他说：“人类有一种不寻常的需求，需要有一个神圣的地方。这就是我们的圣地。”哪怕明知它被夸大了。是的。
Yeah, it is strong. It is strong. And so, I mean, I think this kind of raises, obviously, all kinds of interesting and sensitive questions. So the first obvious question is, which I am not qualified to answer because I'm not an African-American, but does it matter if the history is exaggerated? So I found a number of quotations from African Americans who, who basically say, so, so there's in time in 2004, it ran a story on this whole thing.
卡马拉说，这扇门是一个象征，历史和记忆需要一个强大的象征。而加拿大诗人和小说家迪安·布兰德（Dionne Brand）——
And it quotes a school teacher, a school teacher from Washington, TC who says there's an unusual human need to have a sacred place. This is ours. Even knowing what she, even knowing that it's exaggerated. Yeah. Uh,
我的意思是，她写得真的非常非常迷人，她说这扇门作为一种“缺失”而存在——事实上，这是一个我们不了解的事物，一个我们不了解的地方。换句话说，恰恰因为它并非它所宣称的那样，这才是赋予它力量的原因，因为它指向了所有已经失去的东西。它指向了人们流离失所的方式，整个故事被遗忘的方式，整段历史被抹去的方式。如果你愿意的话，它是一种“缺失的中心”。所以听了迪安·布兰德的这番话，在我看来，这是一种非常费解的方式，试图去证明你正在参观的地方其实并不是你想象的那个地方。但另一方面，我想反驳的论点会是：我们在英国有大量虚假的、捏造的历史遗址，我们赋予了它们各种不一定合理的意义。我的意思是，我一时想不出具体的例子，无法信手拈来。
Camara says that the door is a symbol and that the history and memory needs to have a strong symbol. And Dionne Brand, who's a Canadian poet and a novelist. Um, I mean, she, I think writes really,
好吧，但我认为实际上这种平行对比并不是针对旅游景点的。它应该与朝圣地进行对比。对，是的。实际上这种平行对比并不是针对旅游景点的，而是针对朝圣地的，对吧？你知道的，我们可以……我们之前做过关于基督教的节目，在节目中我们谈到了基督的墓等等。或者你想想圣徒的墓之类的。汤姆，你之前说过关于耶路撒冷的话，你去了耶路撒冷，人们会说“这就是各各他”，这就是这个那个，但实际上是习俗和传统告诉你这就是那个地方，而不是严谨的考证。还有情感投入，对吧？因为一个能够承载访客情感投入的地方，确实会带有一种（我敢说）神圣的品质。
really fascinatingly that the door exists as an absence, a thing, in fact, which we do not know about a place we do not know. So I mean, she, I think, writes really, really fascinatingly that the door exists as an absence, a thing, in fact, which we do not know about, a place we do not know. So in other words, the very fact that it's not what it says it is, is what gives it its power because it points to everything that has been lost. It points to the way that people have been uprooted, that entire stories have been forgotten, that entire history has been erased. And it's a kind of absence centre, if you want to put it like that. So listening to that, Dion Brand, that seems to me a very convoluted way of trying to justify the fact that, you know, the place you're visiting is not the place you think it is. But on the other hand, I suppose the counter argument would be we in Britain have loads of historical sites that are bogus, you know, bogus, fabricated, that we attribute with all kinds of meaning that's really not necessarily justified. I mean, I can't think of them. I can't pluck them off the shelf.
绝对的，你说得对。所以我觉得这扇门的意象足够强大，足以超越它在事实上并非表面上所说的那种情况。我的意思是，我认为它作为一种象征依然经久不衰。我认为关于它的另一件有趣的事情是，它成为联合国教科文组织世界遗产的时间比奥斯威辛集中营还要早一年。我怀疑，在这一切背后潜藏着这样一种方式：与大屠杀有关的遗址开始被包装成游客参观的场所。所以我认为这是一种可能性。我认为关于这一点稍微有些尴尬的是，
Okay, but I think actually the parallel isn't really with tourist sites. It's with pilgrimage sites. Right, yeah. actually the parallel isn't really with tourist sites it's with pilgrimage sites right yeah you know you can you know we've we've done the car but we've and in that we we talked about the the tomb of christ and all you think about um tombs of saints or whatever you were saying about jerusalem tom that you go to jerusalem and people say well this is calvary this is this and actually it's custom and tradition that tells you it's this rather than rigorous and the emotional investment right because a place that that comes to have the emotional investment of its visitors, it does, I think, come to take on a, dare I say, sacral quality.
通过强调那些被带到北美的奴隶，并通过将参观体验量身定制给那些付得起钱的人（换句话说，美国人），一个尴尬的问题是：那些被带到巴西或加勒比海的奴隶呢？是的，他们绝大多数……我的意思是，巴西在奴隶贸易中所占的份额是最大的一部分，不是吗？我们在之前的节目中讨论过这一点。
Absolutely, you're right. So I think the image of the door is powerful enough that it can survive the fact that it isn't actually overtly what it says it is. I mean, I think it does still endure as a symbol. I think the other thing that's interesting about it is that it becomes a UNESCO heritage site the year before Auschwitz does. And I suspect that lurking behind quite a lot of this is the way that sites to do with the Holocaust are starting to be packaged as places for tourists to visit. So I think that that's a possibility. I think that one thing that is slightly awkward about this
是的。而且大概他们不会吸引来自巴西的游客。不会。来到戈雷岛。嗯，可能会有少数几个，但我想不多。不多。而且我认为这也触及了一些问题，这些问题在现在变得比比如 90 年代时要敏感得多。因为当你阅读 90 年代关于这场辩论的内容时，最 striking（引人注目）的其实并不是它的激烈程度，而是相对于今天而言，它是多么的克制。毫无疑问，非洲学者对白人美国学者那种趾高气扬、颐指气使的做法是心存怨恨的。我认为，在美国的学术界里，也有一种感觉，那就是通常是白人历史学家在破坏这些叙事。往往都是白人历史学家在这么做。抱歉，汤姆，我正想插话，在美国关于这个具体问题，在另一个遗址上曾爆发过巨大的风波。
is that by emphasising the slaves who were taken to North America and by tailoring the experience of visiting it to the people who can pay for it, in other words, Americans, one awkward question is, well, what about the slaves who were taken to, say, to Brazil or to the Caribbean? Yeah, who were by far the, I mean, the Brazilian element of the slave trade was the single biggest element, wasn't it? We've discussed that in previous episodes.
对，我想这应该是加纳的埃尔米纳城堡（Elmina Castle）。是的。所以我开始阅读相关资料时想到的正是这个。当时我正在阅读关于 90 年代发生的事情，心想，实际上它当时似乎平静地过去了。因为正如你所说，今年夏天围绕着这个确切的问题，爆发了一场丑闻般的辩论和狂怒。
Yeah. And presumably they're not getting visitors from Brazil. No. To the Island of Gori. Well, there may be a few, but I don't think so. Not many. And I think also that it touches on issues that I think have become a lot more sensitive now than they were, say, in the 1990s. Because what's striking when you read the debate in the 1990s is actually, it's not how vituperative it is, but relative to today, how measured it is. So there's indisputably, you know, there is
是的。美国历史协会（American Historical Association）的主席，一个名叫詹姆斯·斯威特（James Sweet）的人，一位非常杰出的历史学家，我想他在他们的某种时事通讯上写过一篇文章，谈到了他所认为的“当下主义”（present-mindedness）在历史学中的危险，即把历史纯粹变成当代政治的工具。在文章中，他顺便谈到了一件事（隐藏在文章中），他说他是一位非洲历史学家。他和家人去加纳参加婚礼，顺便参观了一个叫埃尔米纳城堡的地方。
a sense of resentment on the part of African scholars, of white American scholars kind of crashing in and laying down the law. And I think there is also, you know, there's a sense in academic departments in America that it is usually white historians who are kind of undermining these narratives. It tends to be white historians. Sorry, Tom, I was just going to jump in and say there's been a colossal furore in the United States about this very issue with regard to a different site. Yeah. So this is Elmina Castle in Ghana, I think. Yeah. So this is exactly what I thought about when I started reading this. And I was reading about what happened in the 1990s and thinking, actually, it seems to have passed off quite quietly. Because as you say, there's been this scandal kind of explosion of debate and fury
他在文章中评论说，你知道，这个地方奇怪的事情在于，它已经变成了一个——他将其描述为（汤姆，你刚才谈到了朝圣），他将其描述为一个“非裔美国人的圣地”。它比加纳的考古或历史遗址更像是一个非裔美国人的圣地。接着他继续说，这让他感到非常不安，因为他说，经过埃尔米纳的非洲人中，不到 1% 去了北美。绝大多数去了巴西或加勒比海，但他们的故事被抹去了，这里被变成了一个——我的意思是，他没有明确这么说，但他基本上是在说，这里被变成了一个相对富裕的非裔美国人的迪士尼化旅游景点，被进行了改造。是的，历史被改造了，
around exactly this issue this summer yeah so the president of the american historical association who was a man called james sweet a very distinguished historian i think he wrote an article in their sort of newsletter talking about what he saw as the dangers of present-mindedness and history of sort of subjecting history to making it purely a vehicle for contemporary politics. And he gives, in the course of this, sort of buried in the article, he talks about how, you know, he's a historian, I think, of Africa. And he and his family went to a wedding in Ghana, and they went on a tour of this place called Amina Castle.
那些被带到巴西的奴隶基本上被抹去了。现在，与 90 年代不同的是（他写这篇文章的时候），虽然这是一篇非常冷静的文章，但却引发了一场轩然大波，他做了我们在《历史的余烬》中讨论过好几次的那种事。他做了一次文化大革命式的卑躬屈膝的道歉。他说：“我深感抱歉。我让所有人失望了。我本不该指出这一点。我疏远了我的同事们。我做了这个那个。”而且实际上，在我们完全不偏袒任何一方的情况下（因为我们不是专家），
And he comments in the article, he says, you know, the weird thing about this place is that it's become, he describes it as, I mean, you talked about pilgrimages, Tom, he describes it as an African American shrine. It's become more of an African American shrine than a Ghanaian archaeological or historical site. And then he goes on to say, he's really troubled by this because he says less than 1% of the Africans who went through Elmina went to North America. The vast majority went to Brazil or the Caribbean, but their stories are kind of erased and it's been turned into, I mean, he doesn't make this explicitly, but he basically is saying it's been turned into a kind of Disney-fied tourist attraction for relatively affluent african americans that it's been retrofitted yeah that the history has been retrofitted exactly and
这是一个非常好的例子，说明了这场对话已经变得多么痛苦，多么令人难以置信地困难。是的，而且我认为这也增加了这样一种观点的分量：这从根本上说是一个几乎具有宗教朝圣性质的地方。而这些问题基本上……可以说是近乎神学的。我认为，随着曾经对民权运动如此重要的基督教教条的公开影响力在美式政治的进步派阵营中逐渐消退，某种程度上，历史已经取代了圣经。它已经取代了神学的维度。
the the slaves taken to brazil have been erased basically now the difference between the 1990s he wrote this um and it's actually a very sober kind of piece there was a massive furore and he did that thing which we've talked about a few times on the rest of history. He did this sort of post-cultural revolution groveling apology. And he said, I'm deeply sorry. I've let everybody down. I should never have pointed this out. I've alienated my colleagues. I've done this, that, and the other. And it's actually, I mean, without us taking sides on this at all, because we're not specialists, you know,
质疑既定的历史理解，已经变得类似于质疑对宗教和上帝的虔诚信仰。正如质疑一个宗教朝圣地的有效性极其敏感一样，同样，很明显，质疑这一点也是如此。这会让人们非常沮丧，因为这里存在两种论点，不是吗？一种观点会说：你们这些白人美国人，或者英国人，或者白人英国播客（正如我不得不说的那样），白人英国播客和白人美国历史学家，不管是谁，都无权说三道四。你知道，这又是殖民主义之类的。有些人会认为这是一种某种形式的知识殖民主义。
it's a very good example of how embittered this whole and how incredibly difficult this whole conversation has become. Yes, and I think also it lends weight to the idea that this is fundamentally about, it's a place of almost religious pilgrimage. And the issues are basically kind of, you know, verging on the theological. I think that as, you know, the overt hold of kind of Christian doctrines that were so important to the civil rights movement have kind of faded from a progressive wing of American politics. In a way, history has come to replace the Bible. It's come to replace the theological
而另一种反驳的论点大概会是：从某种意义上说，字面上的真相（是否有数百万奴隶通过）远不如隐喻上的真相重要。这个机构的辩护者们会这么说，不是吗？是的，绝对是这样。我的意思是，这基本上就是迪安·布兰德所说的，我想。那你怎么看，汤姆？嗯，我认为这取决于去那里的每一个朝圣者个人。我的意思是，我完全理解，如果你是一个非裔美国人，想要与你的祖先以及降临在这些祖先身上的所有苦难和恐怖建立某种联系，而这扇门、这座建筑、这个岛屿已经成为了这样的象征。
dimensions. To question received understandings of history has become akin to questioning devoutly held beliefs about religion and God. And just as questioning the validity of a religious place of pilgrimage is incredibly sensitive, so likewise, it's evident that to question this is similarly um it upsets people very much because there there are two arguments wouldn't there one would be to say you white americans or indeed britain or indeed white british podcasters right right as i've had to say exactly that white british podcasters are white american historians doesn't matter which have no business know, this is yet more colonialism or something. Some people would say sort of some kind of intellectual colonialism.
维度。质疑对历史既有的理解，已经变得类似于质疑对宗教和上帝的虔诚信仰。正如质疑一个宗教朝圣地的有效性极其敏感一样，显然，质疑这一点也同样……嗯，这会让人们非常沮丧，因为这里存在两种论点，不是吗？一种论点会说，你们这些白人美国人，或者英国人，或者白人英国播客，对吧，对吧，就像我不得不说的那样，白人英国播客或白人美国历史学家，不管哪种，都无权……你知道，这简直是又一次殖民主义之类的事情。有些人会认为这是一种某种知识上的殖民主义。
And the other counter argument, I suppose, would be, well, in a way, the literal truth, whether or not millions of slaves pass through is less important than the metaphorical truth. That's what the defenders of this institution would say, wouldn't they? Yeah, absolutely. I mean, that's pretty much what Dion Brand is saying, I think. And what do you think, Tom? Well, I think that that is up to the individual pilgrim who goes there. I mean, I entirely see that if you're an African-American who wants some sense of contact with your ancestor and all the suffering and horror that was inflicted on those ancestors. And this door, this building, this island has come to be
我想，另一个反驳的论点是，从某种意义上说，字面上的真相，无论是否有数百万奴隶通过，都不如隐喻上的真相重要。这个机构的捍卫者会这么说，不是吗？是的，完全如此。我的意思是，我想这差不多就是迪恩·布兰德所说的话。汤姆，你觉得呢？嗯，我认为这取决于去那里的每个朝圣者。我的意思是，我完全理解，如果你是一个非裔美国人，想要感受到与你的祖先的某种联系，以及施加在那些祖先身上的所有苦难和恐怖，而这扇门、这座建筑、这个岛屿已经成为了
a focus for that. I don't think that the kind of statistical evidence for it actually matters one way or the other. I think it's perfectly possible, and I speak with some experience of this, to go to a place where you know that the history may be dubious, but because it's become endowed with particular understanding by generations of people who've gone there before you, the power of it is, you know, that's a legitimate response. But I do also think that, you know, a world of historical inquiry ships that carried people back from Dunkirk, which obviously stirs great feelings of patriotic excitement and all right-thinking Britons. And feel moved by it, while simultaneously knowing that most soldiers were not rescued by little ships. And that had that little ship never gone, the course of the war would be no different. And actually, it's perfectly reasonable to have both those things in your head at once. On the one hand, you're very moved by this little metaphor. But on the other hand, you know as a scholar, that the, as it were, in inverted commas, the real history is very different. And I think the problem with this is if one crowds out the other. Well, I don't think that a myth, a myth isn't a dirty word, I don't think.
我认为那种关于它的统计证据其实并不重要。我觉得完全可以做到——我本人就有些这方面的经验——去一个地方，明知那里的历史可能有些可疑，但由于它被一代又一代到访者赋予了特殊的理解，这种力量本身就是一种合法的回应。但我同时也认为，你知道的，历史探究的世界里，比如那些从敦刻尔克接回人们的小船，显然激起了极大的爱国热情和所有思维正常的英国人的兴奋，并为之感动，同时又清楚地知道，大多数士兵其实并不是被小船救走的，而且即使那艘小船从未出发，战争的进程也不会有任何不同。事实上，脑子里同时容纳这两种想法是完全合理的。一方面，你被这个小小的隐喻深深打动；但另一方面，作为一个学者，你又知道，所谓（加引号的）“真实历史”其实非常不同。我认为问题在于其中一个排挤了另一个。不过我不认为“神话”是个贬义词。
No, agreed. And myths are deserving objects of historical study and the way that they grow and the hold that they have. It's not for historians to patrol them and mock them and poo-poo them and say that they're not valid, because they are. But likewise, I don't think that you can, you know, and I kind of had experience of this writing about religion. In a way, you have to acknowledge the power and the potency of religious myths, of religious teachings, of whatever, while simultaneously adopting a kind of skeptical attitude where there is room for skepticism i also think you can't have a world
没错，完全同意。神话是值得历史研究的对象，包括它们是如何发展起来的以及它们拥有的影响力。历史学家不应该去巡查、嘲弄、贬低它们，或者说它们无效，因为它们确实有效。但同样地，我不认为你可以……你知道的，我写宗教时也有过这种体验。在某种程度上，你必须承认宗教神话、宗教教义等等的力量和潜能，但同时又得采取一种怀疑的态度，为怀疑留出空间。而且我也认为，你不能容忍这样一种世界：
in which james w sweet or whatever his name is or any or philip curtain that they feel they can't talk about this by virtue of their whiteness well i think i think the thing that's interesting is that that curtain obviously never felt that whereas sweet obviously does so uh and i think that that's a kind of reflection of maybe the the uh the the change of culture in in the united states i mean i have to say from my own point of view i was not expecting to arrive at this conclusion i mean i did i i did not know this when I set out. And I think it's a really, really interesting topic. I mean, the test, I suppose, to some extent is if you were in Senegal, would you go? And of course,
在这个世界里，詹姆斯·W·斯威特（James W. Sweet）或随便什么人，或者菲利普·柯廷（Philip Curtin），会因为自己的白人身份而觉得没法谈论这件事。嗯，我觉得有趣的是，柯廷当年显然从没这种感觉，而斯威特显然有。所以，嗯，我认为这在某种程度上反映了也许是美国文化的某种转变。我的意思是，我必须说，从我个人的角度来看，我并没有预料到会得出这个结论。也就是说，我动身时并不知道这一点。而且我觉得这是一个非常非常有趣的话题。我想，某种程度上来说，测试就是：如果你身处塞内加尔，你会去吗？当然了，
I would go, wouldn't you? I would absolutely go, yes. Yes. And it wouldn't bother me that it was slightly confected, but I would want to know. I would want to know the truth as well as seeing the metaphor. But you're saying that as someone whose ancestor wasn't ever taken from the coast of Africa. So I think that the emotional complications of it are more complex for people whose ancestors were taken from there. It's easier for a sceptic to sort of hurl out opinions from the outside, someone who's not personally involved, than I guess it is for a pilgrim, to use your analogy, Tom. Yeah, in a very, very different way. I don't particularly like people
我会去的，你不会吗？我绝对会去，是的。是的。而且即使它有点人为修饰，我也不会介意，但我会想去了解。在看到隐喻的同时，我也想知道真相。但你这么说，是因为你的祖先从未被从非洲海岸带走过。所以我觉得，对于那些祖先曾被从那里带走的人来说，其中的情感纠葛要复杂得多。作为一个不亲自涉事的局外人，一个旁观者，抛出观点要容易得多，而对于一个朝圣者——用你的比喻来说，汤姆——可能就没那么容易了。是的，情况非常非常不同。我不大喜欢别人
casting doubt on the greatness of Alfred. For instance, you know, there are fields in history where we have emotional engagement equally. There is a kind of responsibility for your history, if you're researching history, researching the the past that you have to deal with a certain you know where there's a certain bedrock of fact i don't think that you can ignore it so it wouldn't be a rest his history podcast about the history of senegal if you didn't find a way to bring it back to alfred the great and you have yeah so um no it's an absolutely fascinating story because it raises interesting questions not just about i mean in a weird way this is not a story it started out as a story about senegal and
对阿尔弗雷德大帝的伟大产生怀疑。比如，你知道的，在历史领域中，我们同样有着情感投入。你对历史有一种责任，如果你在研究历史，研究你必须面对的过去，某种程度上你知道那里有事实的基石，我认为你是无法忽视它的。所以，如果这个“历史其余部分”（Rest is History）播客没有找到方法把它拉回到阿尔弗雷德大帝身上，那它就不能算是一个关于塞内加尔历史的播客，对吧？是的，所以……这是一个绝对引人入胜的故事，因为它提出了有趣的问题，不仅仅是关于——从某种奇怪的角度来看，这不是一个关于塞内加尔的故事，它最初是一个关于塞内加尔的故事，
you know the early modern period going up to the 18th century and then newly independent senegal but it's actually ended up being a podcast about the racial politics of america and about the nature of history and myth so like like all great Restless History podcasts, we've been on a journey, Tom. We have. Haven't we? We have. We've been on a journey and we'll be going on another journey tomorrow, excitingly. So we'll see you then. We will see you then. Bye-bye.
涵盖了从早期现代到18世纪，再到新独立的塞内加尔，但它最终却变成了一个关于美国种族政治以及历史和神话本质的播客。所以，就像所有伟大的“历史其余部分”播客一样，我们经历了一段旅程，汤姆。我们确实经历了。不是吗？是的。我们经历了一段旅程，明天我们还将激动人心开启另一段旅程。所以我们到时见。我们到时见。再见。
Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. dot com There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再见。感谢收听《历史其余部分》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听独家节目、提前收听、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。目前本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。